Stacks are a common programming data
structure and many programming interview
questions require knowledge of stacks
tanishq has helped thousands of people
prepare for coding interviews and now
he's going to help you understand the
stack data structure by demonstrating
how to solve a bunch of common coding
interview problems the problems go from
easier to harder and Denise will be
guiding you the entire time my name is
Dani sheltery and I'm very excited to
bring you this course on Stacks so let's
go ahead and get started
hello everyone and welcome let's talk
about the implementation of Stack we are
going to start off with a couple of
examples to understand the reason why
Stacks are built in first place then
we'll look at the implementation level
details of stacks in terms of python and
C plus plus
all right let's get started
now if I ask you the question what do
you see on the screen you might reply
that there looks to be a couple of books
present on a shelf so you can call this
a stack of books
now what would you do if you had to read
the first book the book on the top of
the stack
well you want to read Harry Potter so
you will just pull it out of the stack
you'll remove it from the stack you'll
read it and then you'll push it back on
to the stack once again
now this is simple and fine but what if
you want to read grocking the coding
interview now
what do you do
of course you can drop pulling it out
from the middle but all of these books
are dense and heavy and you don't really
want to disturb the balance of the
elements on the top of the stack so what
you can do is you can take out the first
book
you can take out the second one and then
finally read grocking the coding
interview you read it and then you can
put it back on the stack along with
these two books
what we have just seen is a very
important property of stacks that is
called the leaf ordering
lifo stands for lost in first out
saying that the elements that come into
the stack towards the end that is the
elements that come in the last or the
first ones to get out blast in first out
now this is a property that will exploit
again and again throughout this entire
series it's going to be a central
property and it's the heart of the
reason why we use a stack in many of
these questions
now let's go ahead and formalize the
operations we can do on the stack
because we know that if the leaf
ordering is being followed we have to
use a stack but how do we exactly we use
it
well let's look at a couple of
operations the first operation we saw
was removing items from the top of the
stack
we call this operation formally the pop
operation because we are popping the
elements out from the top of the stack
right so this is going to be the pop
operation
the second operation we saw was to add
the book back onto the stack in other
words we're looking at a push operation
pushes the formal term used to define
saying that we want to add an element
onto the stack in other words we'll push
an element on the stack
now there's a final operation that we do
very commonly and that's the peak
operation now the peak operation simply
says hey go ahead and take a look at the
top of the stack go ahead and take a
peek at the top of the stack
right so these are three operations that
we'll keep in mind all right so now
let's go ahead and actually look at how
these are implemented in terms of python
and C plus plus Java implementations are
pretty close to both of them so even if
you understand just one implementation
way you'll be able to do it in any other
language I have ensured and tried my
best to make sure all of the codes are
language agnostic they can be easily
translated from one language to the
other without having a lot of issues all
right so let's go ahead and actually
look at how we are implementing these
the first thing is how do we initialize
this tag and in Python we're going to
use the list implementation of Stack
because there is no inbuilt internal
class for it we're going to create a
list empty list of our own to initialize
the stack in C plus plus there is so
we're going to use stack
and we're going to have a stack of int
variables and we'll call it as pretty
simple all right how do we push in
Python we do stack dot append and so we
can do stack dot append an item and this
is going to return a non-value that is
it does not return anything we just
append this element onto the top of the
stack
in C plus plus we simply do s dot push
this is going to return a null
all right how do we Peak how do we check
what is the element at the top of the
stack
well in Python the way to do that is to
use stack of -1 that is it is going to
give you the last element on the top of
the stack
right so in this case it's the element
three how do we do it in C plus plus we
simply do s dot top
now remember this is a slight
terminology difference but nothing much
you want to look at the top of the stack
you want to peek at the top of the stack
this is how you do it all right how
about pop
in Python you do directly stack dot pop
and that is going to return your value
three this is a crucial Difference by
the way in Python you're going to get a
return value of 3 however in C plus plus
when you do the pop operation you're not
going to get any return value
all right this is super important
especially when it comes to
implementation keep the language
specific details in your mind
all right the last thing which will also
very commonly use is to check whether
the stack exists or not in other words
is the stack empty or not
so in Python we can simply use the stack
variable and that internally checks its
length so in our case we appended one
element we checked the top of the stack
and then we popped it out so the stack
is currently empty in both the cases
now if you just use stack if you say if
stack colon blah blah blah that is going
to return of value of faults
because the stack is empty right in C
plus plus we can do s dot empty which is
a function that is going to work on the
stack variable and it's going to return
true saying that you know what the stack
is indeed empty
so again small implementation level
details that you have to keep in mind
all right so now that we have a better
understanding of how do we Implement
Stacks let's go ahead and take a look at
a real life test case where Stacks will
be very helpful to understand hello
everyone and welcome back
in the previous video we talked about
how to implement Stacks in terms of C
plus plus and python in this video we're
going to take an example problem
simplify path to build up our
understanding of stacks further in fact
this question is present of both lead
code and interview bit and has been
asked in companies coding interview
rounds many times
this in fact forms a basis for very
important point that how Stacks are
being used in the real world as well
all right let's go ahead and get started
with the formal problem discussion
so we're given a path and this path is a
Unix path given to us and the goal of
this problem is to return the canonical
path now if you're not familiar with how
paths are unique Unix based paths work
I'm going to link to resources down
below so you can check them out first
anyways we're given a path and we have
to follow four conditions to return a
canonical path first we have to start
from a single slash the slash represents
nothing but the root directory
second any two directories are separated
by a single slash so we can have
directory one slash directory 2 slash
blah blah blah
condition 3 says that we should not end
with a trailing slash in other words the
slash at the end of it if there is a
slash at the end of it you have to
return it
all right fourth condition which is the
most important one it says that it only
contains the directories on the path
from the root to the Target that is
there is no period or double period
directories now period and double period
have special meanings period basically
says that wherever you are stay that is
whatever directory you are on currently
just stay over there
double period means take a step back
right so whatever directory you are on
take a step back
all right let's try to uh formally build
up our intuitions and our logic all
right let's take a couple of examples to
understand this better first things we
have a slash home slash SD input the
blue is the input and the green is the
output which by the way is a common
coloring schema followed throughout the
rest of the series so you don't have to
worry about anything
all right so we have slash home slash
and what is the output the output is
slash home that's because we have a
trailing slash at the end of the input
which we remove
all right let's go ahead and take
another example
in this case we have slash dot dot slash
what it means is we start from the root
directory and we have to take a step
back because dot dot really means that
you have to take a step back from the
current directory
and then we have a slash at the end so
of course you can remove the slash at
the end because it's a trailing slash
but now this double dot means that from
the root directory we have to take a
step back but there is no step Backs
from the root directory root directory
is where you start
so in fact this will simply be reduced
to staying on the root directory that is
from the root if you want to take a step
back you will end up at the same route
all right let's take another example and
this time we have slash home slash slash
1337 slash dot slash
first things first remove the trailing
slash now what we notice that between
home and 1337 there are actually two
slashes
what does that mean well in our case the
implementation level detail is that if
there are multiple consecutive slashes
all of them will be useless basically
and we only have to consider one slash
in other words multiple slashes will get
compressed to a single slash so we have
slash home slash 1337
note that the period at the end now
means that we have to stay at the
current directory
so we were at 1337 and we stayed at 1337
let's take a look at one final example
which is going to be the most important
one and this has sort of all of the
conditions mentioned in the question so
let's go ahead and formally try to break
this down to get the logic
first things first we start off with the
single slash which is going to be a root
directory this is by default present in
all the test cases we have to start from
the root directory
now what's the next step we want to go
toward the next value which we see is
home
now what does home mean
who means that we have to go One
Directory forward that is from the root
you have to go to home
all right so pretty simple but now you
get a dot dot
what does this mean this means that you
have to take a step back which means
that from the root you first went to
home but now you have to take a step
back and go back to the root
all right pretty simple again uh work
next we get a dot dot once again and
since we are already at the root taking
another dot dot simply means that go
straight at the root
all right so now we get a slash uh TMP
and what does that mean
that means that now we have to take a
step forward we have gotten the
directory and so we'll go to slash TMP
and then we have a bunch of slashes
together that we have two slashes that
just gets compressed to one single slash
and then we have a DOT
now dot simply means that wherever you
are stay so you viewer are the slash
temp directory and we'll stay over there
and of course the last slash at the end
is just a trailing one so we'll remove
it
in other words the final answer we get
is slash TMP as we saw in the first line
of this slide
so now let's go ahead and formally talk
about how did we do this
how are we going to implement this going
forward and going backward thing
if you have guessed it yes you are right
we have to use the data structure
of course this is a playlist of our Sac
we have to use a stack
but why do we use it again
whenever we have a directory like home
or slash TMP we have to take a step
forward and whenever we have dot dots we
have to take a step backwards and a good
way to simulate that is by using a stack
all right let me go ahead and show you
how this formally works out
so the first thing we get is uh home so
home means that we have to move forward
which means that we will push the value
home on to the stack
that is we'll append this value to the
top of the stack
now we get a dot dot next what does that
mean that means that we have to go back
One Directory in other words we have to
pop the element out of the stack
right we get a dot dot once again but
the stack is already empty what do we do
this is a special condition and we have
to say that you know what if the stack
is empty you can't really pop anything
and we don't really have to pop either
we were at the root and we'll stay at
the root so the stack remains as is
then we have TMP so what do we do next
this is a directory so we append it we
push this value on the top of the stack
now we get a DOT what does that mean
that means whatever directory you are at
stay there in other words the stack
remains unchanged
so if we have to formalize what can we
say
let's focus on the core Parts first
things first how do we start
the way we start is at the root and that
is nothing but the cue to initialize the
stack
right whenever we start we're going to
initialize the stack now directory means
taking a step forward what does that
mean
that means that we're going to append an
element onto the top of the stack in
other words we are going to push this
directory in the stack
right and what does dot dot mean dot dot
now means that we have to pop we have to
go One Directory backward
so whatever you append it just pop it
back again
and then finally we have a DOT which
means that we really do nothing do no
operations
and this is really it this is it for the
logic of this problem let's go ahead and
look at the optimize solution and we're
going to code it up from scratch all
right let's go ahead and look at how do
we implement this question in terms of
python code
the first thing we'll do is initialize
the stack to be an empty stack
and then we'll start to iterate over the
directories
in the paths
now obviously the path given to us is
going to be a string
which is separated by these flashes so
each of them directories
that is any two directories are
separated by a single slash
so we have to say go ahead and do path
dot split
by the Slash
that is
get me the individual directories and
we'll see what to do next
so what's the first condition we saw
remember from the code remember from the
logic the first condition we can say is
that you know what if you get a DOT that
is if you get the operation where the
directory
we have to move to is a DOT that means
that wait don't really do anything
right we don't really do any operation
on the stack if we get a single Dot
so it was the other case we'll have the
directory
is what if it's a double lot what do we
do
if it's a double dot we have to do an
operation called pop
that is we have to go back one step we
have to pop the element from the top of
the stack so we'll do stack dot pop
but now is a very important Edge case
right this is a very important condition
I'm going to write see it's not always
the case that you can pop this directory
from the stack
that is for stack dot pop to work you
have to ensure that stack is not empty
because if the stack is empty and you
pop an element out of the stack that is
going to give you an error whether it be
a python or C plus plus or Java all of
these languages are going to give you an
error if you pop an element out of the
empty stack so first we'll go ahead and
check hey you know what if the stack
exists only then go ahead and do the
stack dot pop operation
what do we do else what do we do
otherwise
well in case this Jack is already empty
and we get a double dot what does that
mean
on an empty stack which means that we
are at the root and we get a double dot
which means that from the root we have
to move a step back
which means that we just have to stay at
the root so the stack remains as is and
this condition in the else condition we
don't really have to do anything
all right it was the final case what the
final case is say that go ahead and
append this value to the stack append
this directory
to the stack all right so this is it
right we're going to return what
well one of the conditions the first
condition and the question says that the
path starts with a single slash
so we're going to go ahead and start
with the single slash
and since we have all the directories in
the stack let's go ahead and do the join
operation so we'll do uh
join Dot
start
so what this is going to do is iterate
over all the elements in the stack and
join them with a slash in the middle
all right so before we go ahead and run
this code by the way there's one more
condition that is important to know
see because directories can have a case
where we have say double slashes that is
if we have slash home slash Foo slash
these double slashes are going to give
us an issue
because when we split when we split this
path by slash it means that there is
going to be a case where there is one
slash and then there's a empty string
and then another slash
in other words what I'm saying is we
have to add one more condition saying
that if the directory
is actually empty
that is if there were multiple
consecutive slashes
then we don't have to do anything like
that
right if we get multiple slashes we just
look at it as one slash
and we don't really do anything
right so
this is it for the logic of the code and
let's go ahead and test this out on a
bunch of input test cases
looks to be correct so let's go ahead
and submit this
and we get it accepted
all right so this is it for the solution
to the problem simplify path
hello everyone and welcome back let's
talk about the problem main stack on
interview bit
all right so the goal of this problem is
to design a stack that supports a bunch
of operations first Operation Push
we have to push an element X onto the
stack very simple
second operation you have to design an
operation that returns as the top of the
element that is it is going to see what
is the top of the stack and return it
third operation we have to design a
function that pops the value out of the
stack we have to remove the top element
and return it right so all of these
three operations up till now are
something we've already seen that are
like very basics of what a stack is
but now there is a fourth operation
given to us getman
this function is going to return a value
X which is going to be the minimum value
of the entire stack
now the only constraint that is given to
us is that all of the queries should run
in constant time that is we should take
order of one time each
now how do we start to think about a
solution
once since the problem is about using a
stack let's go ahead and create a stack
and we'll start to see what do we do
once we get the queries all right so
this is the simulation will run let's
say we get the um
query to push the value 7 onto the stack
so now this is how the stack is going to
look with the value 7 on top of it
if you get push 3 we'll just Add 3 to
the top of the stack
we hit push nine
we add 9 to the top of this track
now let's go ahead and say that we get
the query getman
what do we do at this point of time
gateman query says that go ahead and get
the minimum element of the entire stack
which means that a naive way to proceed
about it is to go over all of the
elements inside of the stack one by one
and find the minimum value
in this case we find the 3 is the
minimum value so we'll go ahead and
return 3.
now let's say that we get another
operation called pop so we'll go ahead
and pop the element out of the top of
the stack then let's say we get uh get
min again
what are we going to do iterate over the
entire stack go over all of the elements
one by one and return three we realize
that three is the minimum value right so
let's go ahead and say we get another
value another Operation Push one so we
will add one to the top of the stack
getman says
well
get me the minimum value of all the
elements in the stack which means that
the value will be 1.
now if you realize what we have been
doing up till now is all of the
operations like portion the pop even the
top are going to take order of one time
to run as it does in normal stack
however the gate main operation is kind
of a pain
that is because we have to iterate over
the entire stack one by one taking order
of end time where n is the number of
elements in the stack
this means that there has to be a better
way to do it we have to figure out a way
to answer the getman query in order of
one time
all right so let's go ahead and talk
about the optimization
this is one of those questions where if
you don't know what to do you really
would have no idea on how to proceed
and in these kind of questions what we
are going to do is we're going to create
another stack that's right we're not
doing just going to have one stack we
are going to have two stacks the first
is the blue one which we already saw
which will handle the queries like push
and the Bob in the top
but we will also have a green stack
which is going to keep a track of the
minimum value we have seen up till now
let me go ahead and show you the
simulation once again and that will make
a lot more sense
because it's a beautiful way to approach
this problem right so let's go ahead and
say we get the query push second we get
the request to do push seven so we'll
just add 7 on the top of the stack now
this is the stack we're going to append
it to we're going to add it to the blue
stack directly whatever query we get we
directly apply it to the bluestack
the green stack will simply reflect the
changes of the blue one
so since we added 7 to the stack the
minimum value of the stack is now 7 so
we'll add 7 to the stack
now let's say we get a push 3 Operation
what do we do
because this is a blue case we'll simply
add 3 to the top of the stack but we'll
have the three reflect changes in the
green stack as well that is the green
stack is now going to store a value that
is the minimum of 7 and 3 because we
have two elements on the top of the
stack right
so we're going to have minimum of 3 and
7 and so we'll store three
now let's say we go ahead and get the
value as uh let's say we get a push nine
operation
now the top of the blue stack will have
nine but the top of the green stack will
have the value 3.
and that is because 3 is the minimum
value of 3 and 9 which is going to be
the minimum value of the entire stack
all right so now what do we do now we if
we get a query get min what do we do
simply look at the top of the green
stack and return that as the answer we
are not going to pop out anything at
this point of time right
as soon as we get a get main query we
are going to Peak at the top of the
green stack and return that value
now let's say we get a operations which
says go ahead and pop the element out of
the stack
so this is going to pop the element 9
and now we have to make the green stack
we reflect changes of the blue one since
we removed an element we will also have
to remove the element from the green
stack
now what if we get a getman query once
again
if we get a getman query we'll simply
look at the top of the stack
and since the value 3 will return 3.
right so now let's say we get a push one
operation what do we do one gets
directly pushed onto the green sorry
pushed on to the blue stack and the
green stack is now going to reflect the
changes green stack is going to have the
value the minimum of three and one that
is it is going to take the minimum of
the previous element on the top of the
stack
the one which we got currently
all right so now if I get uh get men
again what do we do
look at the top of the stack and return
one as the answer
all right so this is really it for the
logic of the code what we have done is
we have figured out a way to implement
the solution using two stacks so let's
go ahead and initialize
sorry
and uh let's go ahead and create self
dot stack
and we'll have self dot Min stack right
these are the two stacks that we
initialize this is the green one
and this is the blue one all right now
what do we do when we get a push query
the stack the stack that we have the
blue one is simply going to reflect the
changes directly so we'll say when we
get a push operation self dot stack dot
append X nothing special
but what do we do about the Min stack
Min stack is going to reflect the
changes so I'm going to say
self.minstack dot append
well I want to append the minimum value
of the current X that is I'm going to
take the current value and find the
minimum with the Min stack top
so we'll go ahead and do the main stack
find the Top Value and take their
minimum right pretty simple
this is exactly what we discussed before
but now we have to take care about one
thing this is a common thing which we
have to take here across all the stack
questions see what we have tried to do
here is that we have to try to access
the minus one element on the Min stack
that is I'm going to find the top
element of the main stack but this will
only work
when will it work this will only work if
the self dot main stack is not empty
but if it's empty what do we do
look if it's not empty we'll simply take
the Min of X and the top of the stack
but if it's an empty stack let's just go
ahead and directly append this element
to the main stack so we'll do self dot
mainstack dot append
X
all right this makes sense
so now what do we do when we get the pop
operation
remember we have to ensure that all of
the changes in the stack
are reflected in the green one as well
so when we do self.stag.pop
we have to do the pop operation for the
Min stack as well
again one more Edge case one more
condition you can only do pop when you
can only do pop if the stack is not
empty so we'll say if
self dot stack exist that is there are
elements inside of the stack then you
can do pop
but if the stack is empty pop will
really do nothing so we'll just say it's
pass right now what do we do when we get
top again uh here we have to return what
is value at the top of the stack so
we'll do stealth dot stack
minus 1.
but wait a second it is not guaranteed
that the self of TAC of minus 1 is going
to exist
in other words the stack might be empty
so if
self dot stack exists well then you can
go ahead and do this
but what do we do otherwise
the stack is empty and we are asked to
return the top element of the stack
well look at the condition
in the question mentions something
what should top do on an empty stack
return -1 so in this case we are going
to return
-1 right what do we do when we get get
min now
remember
in the top function we return the top of
the stack which is the stop of the blue
stack but in the getman function we're
going to return the top of the green
stack so we'll say if self
self.minstax exist well then you can go
ahead and return the self dot main stack
stop
but if it does not
go ahead and return
-1 you can see that there's a lot of
paddles between gateman and the top
that's because the only thing that
changes is the stack in top we use the
blue stack and in the green one green
one is used in the getman function
all right let's go ahead and test this
out quickly
looks like this is correct so we'll go
ahead and submit this
all right we get it accepted and this is
it for the solution to the problem men
stack on interview bit all right that's
it hello everyone and welcome back now
this is after our first section on where
we discuss the stack related questions
where we built up our understanding of
stacks the implementation level details
along with a couple of example problems
to help us understand things better
in this section we're going to focus on
parentheses related questions which is
actually going to be a step up from the
previous one and is going to lead us to
calculator related questions in the next
section
now why are we talking about parentheses
questions in stack playlist
you will get the questions answered very
soon what we're going to look at is a
bunch of example problems like valid
parentheses longest valid parentheses
written in braces and many more
these are commonly asked in interviews
and applying Stacks to these problems
becomes a crucial part of understanding
Stacks themselves
all right now we will go ahead and take
a look at an example and we'll try to
build up our understanding of
parentheses related questions and
calculated related questions later on
because what we're going to understand
is the reason why we use Stacks inside
of these parentheses questions in the
first place
all right so given this expression to
you let me ask you the question if I
give this to you on a paper and I'll
give you a pen to solve this how would
you go about solving this kind of
expression
the first thing you would want to do is
look at the innermost brackets that is
the innermost brackets contain the value
D so let's go ahead and evaluate that
first
right you want to focus on the innermost
first and then slowly zoom out to the
outermost now what do we do zoom out to
we would zoom out to B minus D in The
Next Step and this would then finally
lead us to the entire expression
what we have done is nothing but parsing
now parsing is a fancy word for what it
means is
we have to figure out the structure of
the input that is it parsing means to
figure out how the input is laid out
now why do we want to understand the
structure of the input why is this kind
of thinking helpful
let's take a look at a simple example
we'll take this simple example and in
this case we have two opening round
brackets and two closing round brackets
now if I ask you the question can you
tell me
what is the corresponding opening
bracket to this current closing round
bracket that is I've highlighted this
closing round bracket for you can you
tell me which of these
is the corresponding current opening
bracket
pretty simple to answer because we
already know the way we do this is by
taking the bracket that is the closest
we figured that this opening bracket
came in the last and was the first one
to get a result
wait a second
the bracket which came in the last was
the first one to get resolved that is
we're following something of the sort of
a leaf ordering
that's right this is the reason why we
use Stacks in these parentheses
questions
because when to use stack is answered
whenever we see Lee for ordering right
so we have seen that we have to use a
stack in parentheses questions and in
calculator related questions as well but
how exactly do we use it
how do we use tax in these kind of
questions
what we are going to do is we are going
to do a left to right parsing as I
explained earlier parsing is a fancy
word what it simply means is we have to
understand the structure of the input we
have to break it down step by step and
understand okay this is what gets
resolved first and this is what get
resolves later on now left to right
simply means that we're going to iterate
from the left to the right
okay enough talking let me actually show
you with an example so this is the
example case we took earlier and we have
initialized an empty stack on this
all right so what do we do next
well here's a rule that you have to keep
in mind
anything that you get which is a opening
bracket a character Like A B C D or an
operator like plus minus division
multiplication anything of that sort you
get you simply append it to the stack
that is you push
everything except close brackets on the
top of the stack
here's what I mean say we get this
opening round bracket we do nothing but
push this on the top of the stack
then we get a push it on top of the
stack then we get Plus
open curly bracket B minus open around
bracket d
the only time V and B do not append
items on a stack is when we get a
closing bracket this is important this
is very important
if we get a opening bracket a character
or an operator whatever
we directly added to the stack without
thinking without having second thoughts
but as soon as we get a closing bracket
of any kind we have to start thinking
all right so I already asked you the
question of what this closing bracket
actually closes what is the
corresponding opening bracket and if you
see in the stack we actually have that
value with us we have this opening round
bracket on the top on this stack here
however that is not the top element and
it might not always be obvious which of
these opening brackets am I closing
right because we have a currently we
have a closing bracket in our hand and
we want to figure out hey what is the
area that I close
what is the area what is the expression
that needs to be resolved first because
I'm following the leaf forwarding again
so what we do is we'll keep on popping
these elements of the top of the stack
till we see a corresponding opening
round bracket here's what I mean as soon
as we get this closing around bracket
we'll go ahead and start looking for the
opening round bracket so we'll pop out D
because D is not opening round bracket
and so D sort of in an intermediate
state
we don't really know if D is part of a
valid expression or not so we'll just
keep it hold
right now what we get
on the top of the stack you see that
there's a opening round bracket
what does that mean currently look at
the yellow marker we are at a closing
round bracket and on the top of the
stack we have found a opening round
bracket in other words everything inside
of both of these brackets is going to
get resolved
both of these brackets satisfy each
other both of them resolve each other
and everything in the middle of them
will get satisfied so D is actually part
of a valid string now right the brackets
are balanced in a way
all right so now let's go ahead and look
at what happens later on we'll keep on
iterating and we get a closing curly
bracket now what do we do again this is
a closing bracket so we have to be
careful
what do we do we look at the value on
the top of the stack this is clearly not
opening curly bracket so we'll go ahead
and remove it but we'll keep it on hold
minus maybe or may not be a part of a
valid string
all right so we have B now again B is
not an opening curly bracket so we can't
care about that
so B and minus are both at an
intermediate State we can't really see
anything about
what do we get now
we have a opening curly bracket in other
words we have found the opening for this
closing curly bracket which we are on
currently
in other words what does that mean
that means we have resolved everything
in the middle of these two brackets so
you can see somehow that kind of
structure is being followed again we
have sort of parsed the input we're
trying to understand how this input is
laid out all right so now what do we do
next let's go ahead and keep on
iterating so we get a start again this
is not a closing bracket so we'll just
add it directly we get a c not a closing
bracket added directly and now we get a
closing round bracket what do we do next
what do we do think about it
we're gonna keep on popping these
elements out one by one we're gonna keep
on popping them out till we get an
opening round bracket and as soon as we
get an opening round bracket what do we
know
we know that everything in the middle of
both of these brackets is going to be
validated
and this is the way we have figured out
how to parse the input
we knew that we had to use a stack
because we could see the leaf ordering
being followed in the way brackets were
opens and closed
and then we figured out how to exactly
go about looking at the opening and the
closing of brackets by using a left to
right parsing
now a quick small implementation level
detail is how do we implement this
in the previous example I showed you we
were appending these brackets and the
pluses and the minuses directly and you
can do that you can directly add the
elements or you can also add the indices
now uh different questions will require
different cases but in general if you
want one single template just use
indices
that's because if you append indices to
the stack you will obviously have a
mapping to the elements as well but if
you only append elements to the stack
you might forget which indice which
index it came from
anyways that's a very small level detail
but still important to keep in mind just
make sure you are consistent with what
you are appending to the style whether
it be elements or indices right so what
is the conclusion let's summarize this
once more we figured out in all the
parentheses and the calculated questions
we have to use a stack why is that
because these brackets were following a
leaf ordering last ones to get in were
the first ones to get out they were the
first ones to get a result
and how did we figure out how do we use
it we know we have to use a stack and we
iterate it from the left to the right
and we parsed the input we figured out
the input and the structure of the
string that is given to us and finally
you can either add elements or the
indexes to the stack that's upon you and
that's a small detail you can take care
of later on as well
all right so keeping these three rules
in mind let's go ahead and work out a
couple of problems to fully get
comfortable with parentheses related
questions hello everyone and welcome
back let's talk about the problem valid
parentheses on lead code this by the way
is a slight bit modification of the
problem balanced parentheses on entropy
bit if we are able to solve this you you
will obviously be able to copy paste the
code and get it accepted for balanced
parentheses as well anyways this entire
solution is based upon the understanding
from the previous video where we talked
about the introduction to all
parentheses based questions we figured
out how do we use the leaf ordering how
do we go from the left to right and
pause the input and the way we exactly
Implement Stacks so if you haven't
checked that video out I'll highly
recommend you do because this solution
is based entirely on top of that in fact
it's going to be a very easy version of
what we have seen before
all right let me go ahead and show you
and take you step by step throughout
this problem
given a string s containing only
brackets we have opening and closing
brackets of the type round curly and
square
and the goal of this problem is to
return true if s is valid and false
otherwise
so looking at the example cases we have
the first one Returns the output issue
because the closing and the opening
brackets match and mix and match
appropriately
in the second case however there is a
spray opening curly bracket which never
gets closed in fact it is trying to
close the round bracket which is going
to be invalid so we have to return false
in this case
all right let's go and talk about the
intuitions and the observations needed
to solve this question a bit more
formally
we'll take the same test case and we'll
try to build our understanding from this
now if we focus on the opening round
bracket we see that it gets close
towards the very end we get a closing
round bracket towards the very end so
both of them resolve each other out
all right what about the opening and the
closing curly brackets well both of them
again mix and match well and this
closing bracket is able to close the
appropriate opening bracket that is the
closing query bracket wants an opening
curly bracket to be present before it
and it is so we can see that this is
also a valid case
what about the square brackets again the
opening square brackets gets closed by
the appropriate closing bracket
so this is also valid which means that
everything inside of this test case
mixes and match as well the opening
brackets are closed by the appropriate
closing brackets so we return true in
this case
right let's take another example and
this time we have something more
interesting going on because we have the
same number of opening and the closing
brackets that is for one opening around
bracket we have one closing round
bracket one opening curly bracket we
have one closing curly bracket
but the ordering in this case is meshed
up
that's because if you can notice this
closing round bracket is trying to close
an opening curly bracket
obviously this will never work
because this closing curly bracket sorry
this closing round bracket wants to
close an opening round bracket it cannot
close the opening curly bracket so
brackets in this case do not match
and obviously this is contrasted with
the case where we have the same number
of opening and the closing ground and
curly brackets
but one of them is invalid and the other
is valid
so clearly ordering matters
and if you notice
the input has to follow this Leaf
ordering that we discussed in the
previous video as well that is the last
bracket to get in should be the first
one to get out
and that was sort of the intuition
behind using a stack and we also
discussed how do we go from the left to
the right and parse the input
let's go ahead and do that in the next
step
one more thing we also discussed that if
the brackets open add them directly if
the brackets close check what they are
closing
that is if you get any kind of opening
bracket just add it to the stack without
thinking Twice But as soon as you get a
closing bracket what do you do as soon
as you get a closing bracket you have to
check whether it closes the right
opening bracket or not
all right let's go ahead and go ahead
with the simulation the first thing
we'll do keep on iterating from the left
to the right we get the first element as
an opening round bracket opening bracket
what do we do add directly no thinking
then we may trade forward and we get
opening curly bracket again since this
is opening we'll just add it directly no
thinking twice
but now what do we get
we get a curly closing bracket now we
have to be careful we have to be very
careful in what we do
because as soon as we get a closing
curly bracket what do we expect
we expect that it closes an opening
curly bracket because no other case will
work out this closing curly bracket
cannot close an opening round bracket or
an opening square bracket it can only
close and opening curly bracket so now
following that leaf ordering again we
look at the top of the stack what is the
top of the stack
it's a opening curly bracket so that's
great but this current closing around
sorry this current closing curly bracket
we found an appropriate opening curly
bracket in other words both of them
validate each other and satisfy each
other pretty nice right all right let's
go ahead and continue iterating and we
get an opening round bracket since it's
opening we added directly
but now what to have what happens next
we get a closing square bracket
what does that mean well this closing
square bracket comes in and requests
that hey uh can you get me an opening
square bracket because that is who I can
satisfy right I can mix and match well
with the closing or sorry opening square
bracket
so we go ahead and look at the top of
the stack and we see that it's the
opening round bracket instead
what does this mean
this means that this closing bracket is
actually invalid
and so this was ill-validate the entire
expression as soon as we get one invalid
case one parentheses messes up as soon
as one guy messes up the entire string
gets canceled think about it that way
right
now just to another example is uh what
happens if we had a closing round
bracket
what would happen in this case
in this case what would happen is we
would be able to mix and match well with
the top of the stack
so we can say that you know what this
closing round bracket will be able to
match with the stack top both of them
resolve each other and we can move
forward with our lives again this is a
closing round bracket we'll check the
top of the stack is it an appropriate
opening bracket
yes it is so let's go ahead and close
that and we're done
now what do we see happening at the end
all of these brackets are validated all
of the opening brackets have been closed
and this is the reason why stack is
empty
remember this is another important
condition which you might miss
the stack should be empty at the end and
what it says is really is that all of
the brackets that opened which we put
into the stack remember all the opening
were put into the stack and all the
closing were removing them from the side
so if at the end the stack is empty that
is a good sign because we were able to
close all the brackets that ever opened
now what's another case that could
happen let's say that we have another
curly bracket towards the end now this
is the entire string what would happen
in this case we would add it to the
stack but this would never get resolved
in other words it will be left alone and
it would make the entire expression
entire parentheses invalid
right so it's very important for us to
follow a couple of conditions let's go
ahead and formalize the logic and that
should make a lot more sense
all right let's go ahead and talk about
the code for the is valid parentheses
question all right so first things first
we'll go ahead and create a stack which
is going to be an empty list
next we want to create a mapping from
the uh
closing bracket to the opening bracket
that is for this closing bracket for a
closing curly bracket I expect an
opening curly bracket to be present on
the top of this track right this is
something we've discussed already we
have to do the same for opening and
closing brackets for all the kind now
all right cool so now that we have
created the mapping we can finally go
ahead and start to iterate from the left
to the right so we'll go over all the
characters in The String given to us
now first things we'll check is that if
the character is a opening bracket if
it's round
square or curly opening bracket then
don't think twice
just append it to the stack
right
because as soon as we get a opening
bracket we directly add it to the stack
without thinking twice this is something
we've already established
else else what do we do
in the else condition things get more
interesting because now I have to say
you know what to check if the mapping of
this character if the mapping of this
closing bracket maps to the correct
value present on the stack top
that is for the closing bracket that I
have right now can you check if it maps
to the correct value that is the opening
bracket of curly type on the top of the
stack because if it does then it's good
then it's good right
and we'll see you know what since both
of them match both of them resolve each
other so I'm just going to do stack dot
pop I'm going to remove this bracket
that matched
all right what do we do in the ash
condition what do we say when there's a
mismatch
as soon as there's a mismatch I'm going
to return false I'm going to be
merciless as soon as you guys miss much
I'm going to return false right away
okay there's one more thing that we need
to take care of
see I've tried to access the stack of -1
here what have we learned up till now
you just cannot access this stack of -1
just whenever you want you have to
ensure if the stack exists
and only when the stack exists you can
do all of these operations well what do
you do otherwise
what if the stack does not exist
what if the stack does not exist and you
have a closing curly bracket or closing
bracket of any kind rather
in that case that closing bracket is
trying to close something that doesn't
exist in other words we can just set it
on pause right away
all right so at this point are we done
can we return true
not so fast this is where another
mistake can occur
we have to ensure that the stack is
empty we have to ensure that the length
of the stack is equal to equal to zero
why because we already saw this example
over here
in this case we reached the end of the
iteration and we had one curly bracket
remaining in the stack
and this curly bracket was never
resolved it was never popped out of the
stack
which means that it Still Remains
unresolved to this date
in other words this entire expression
became invalid just because the stack
was not empty
in just to reframe what does empty stack
mean empty stack really means that
although the brackets that were input
into the stack all of the opening
brackets that were ever inputted into
the stack have been closed
all right cool so let's go ahead and run
this code and this gets accepted so
let's go ahead and submit this once and
we get it accepted as well
all right cool so this is it for the
solution to the problem valid
parentheses hello everyone and welcome
back
let's talk about the problem redundant
braces on interview bid
now just a quick aside if you haven't
watched the video introduction to
parentheses question I highly recommend
you watch it because we are directly
going to use rules and logic that we
formed in that video
inside of this question because we're
going to apply things directly without
talking about it much that's going to
make the solution a lot simpler all
right anyways let's talk about the
problem statement first given a string a
containing operators round braces and
letters so we have a bunch of operators
like plus minus multiplication divide
then we have our round braces so we have
the opening and closing round brackets
and a bunch of letters
the goal of this problem is to return
one if a has redundant braces and zero
otherwise
all right so let's go and take a look at
some examples how do they find redundant
in the first case we have a redundant
brace because we have two sets of round
brackets wrapping the a plus b when we
only ever need one
in the second case we see that there are
no redundant brackets because we're
going to make use of every single one of
them
so let's go ahead and take a look at
some observations and logic from test
cases given and really there is just one
single observation that we need to pull
out from these
what is that let's try to build up to it
the first test case we see is a plus b
wrapped in these two sets of braces
why is there redundancy in this because
instead of 2 we can just use one right
let's take a look at the last test Keys
here we have a simple letter A which is
wrapped inside of these parentheses
but it looks like we don't really need
this the example and the problem sector
says that you know what this is a case
of redundant braces because you don't
really need to wrap a in anything else
and in the middle we see that we have a
plus a plus b in this case there are no
redundant braces we're using every
single thing
now what do you notice
there's actually one thing in common
with all of them which makes the
solution work and this is the central
observation of the entire problem
what is the observation
the observation is there should be no
operators in between these braces so in
the first one you see between the first
set of braces and the second set of
braces there are either no letters and
no operators right there are no letters
or operators
in the second one there are both letters
and operators and a third one there is a
letter but there is not an operator
right so we have to ensure that there
are no operators between any two sets of
braces because if we can make this
condition work then
will have a case of redundant braces
all right just a quick aside what are
some of the rules that we saw earlier
rules when do we decide when we have to
use a stack
we use a stack whenever we see a leaf
ordering being followed and that is true
for all parentheses questions so in this
question we're also going to use a stack
however we're going to use it we're
going to go from the left to the right
and parse the input see what uh
structure this input is following
and finally how do we implement this in
this question the elements are the
bigger uh Focus instead of the indices
so let's just focus on elements let me
actually go ahead and show this to you
right as we discussed there should be no
operators between any two sets of braces
this is something we'll keep in mind as
we go through the example
all right so let's go ahead and iterate
from the left to the right one by one so
let's say we have the first element and
that's the opening bracket so let's just
push it on to the stack again if we get
opening bracket if we get a operator or
if we get a letter we push that onto the
stack
the only time we don't push an element
onto the stack is when we get a closing
bracket because then we need to be more
careful again this is something I've
already explained in the parentheses
questions uh the introduction to
parentheses questions video if you
haven't checked it out if you haven't
understood it well enough go ahead and
dive into advanced mode right cool so
we'll go ahead and continue iterating we
get another opening round bracket so
we'll just add it to the stack now we
get a
then we get plus and then we get B
nothing special these are just opening
brackets operators or letters we add
them directly onto the stack without any
question
only when we get a closing bracket then
we have to be careful all right so now
that we have gotten a closing bracket
let's try to be more careful with what
we do
what's the first thing we do well this
closing round bracket is looking for an
opening round bracket to close make
sense
so we look at the stack top well that's
an element B
um B is not really useful for us so
let's just go ahead and pop that and
we'll keep it as an intermediate state
we don't really know if B is useful or
not
and then we see a plus now what does
that mean look at the condition on the
top right
the question wants that there should be
no operators if you want to have a
redundant brace
that is if you can find an operator in
this case we have found an operator that
means that the expression that we're
going to interrupt in these two opening
and the closing round brackets is
actually going to be a non-redundant one
we need those braces in this case again
that is just how the problem is defined
so now since we have found an operator
let's go ahead and keep that in mind and
we'll keep on popping these elements out
one by one again so we go we pop out
plus
and then we also pop out a but now what
do we have on the stack top there is a
opening round bracket
and what do we have currently the
pointer is pointing to it's losing round
bracket which means that everything
inside of this has to be considered
together right
now since we found an operator What can
we say about this current highlighted
section
we can say that this is actually non
redundant case so this is actually a
valid case of how braces are being used
so let's not touch this we'll just keep
on iterating forward
so now we get a plus again it is not a
closing bracket so we can just add it
directly no thinking again opening
bracket good to go C good to go
ah but now we have a closing bracket so
let's try to be more careful this time
now what do we do
the first thing we do is look at the
stack top we have our element C again
it's not an opening bracket so let's
just pop it out keep it as a
intermediate state
and now what do we have we have a
opening bracket so we have found an
opening bracket for this current closing
bracket what does that mean
that means that the entire highlighted
expression is what we have to look at
right now
but look at this
there was no operator that we found in
the middle
right there was no operator in this
highlighted expression
which means that there are redundant
array cells
that's correct so this is what it means
we have found a redundant bracket and we
can return true that yes indeed there
are redundant brackets in this input
all right so let's go ahead and take a
look at the optimized solution and we'll
go ahead and code this up
right so this is going to be the code
where we start from an empty stack again
very simple and then we'll go ahead and
iterate over all the characters in the
input string right
now as I mentioned what is the first
condition
the first condition is if you get a
letter if you get a operator or an
opening bracket that is if you get
anything other than a closing bracket
this is directly appended to the stack
no thinking at all
all right when it goes to the edge
condition we have to be a bit more
careful
so in this condition what we'll do is
we'll keep a track of the count and this
count keeps a track of account of the
number of operators we have seen because
remember that is what is going to tell
us whether a bracket or whether an
expression inside of the input is
redundant or not so we'll start the
count from 0 and we'll say you know what
since we have found this uh closing
ground bracket let's just go ahead and
keep on popping these elements out from
the top of the stack one by one till we
get a
opening round bracket right till we get
a opening round bracket so we'll go
ahead and say now if the Pod is actually
an operator
that is if it's any of the plus minus
star or Division if the character is any
of these operators then I want you to do
count plus one
in other words since we have found a
positive number of counts of The
Operators whatever the expression is
going to be is going to be a valid
non-redundant expression
and of course at the end of this while
loop we are going to do a stack dot pop
because we want to pop out this uh
opening bracket we don't really have any
use for this at all
anyways now what do we do
once we're done with this entire
iteration of this while loop we're gonna
check what the condition is
we're gonna say if the count is zero
that is if the count did not change at
all in other words we did not encounter
any operators if we did not encounter
any operators return one we have found
the case of redundancy
and if not we'll just keep on going
forward going forward again and again
and again and if throughout the entire
iteration of this entire string you find
no such redundancy then you can safely
return 0. that is the entire string is
non-redundant
right so let's go ahead and test this
out it looks like it works and we'll go
ahead and submit this as well
cool so this gets accepted and this is
it for the solution to the problem
redundant braces hello everyone and
welcome back let's talk about the
problem minimum removed to make valid
parentheses this by the way is a medium
level question on lead code and we're
going to use this problem to build up
our solution for longest valid
parentheses as well in fact this
solution is going to convert that hard
problem into an easy one I'm not even
kidding all right let's go ahead and get
started with the problem statement
so we're given a string that contains
opening and the closing round brackets
and lowercase English letters
the goal of this problem is to remove
the minimum number of parentheses to
make S valid
so in the first case we see that there
are two opening brackets and one closing
bracket and we see that we have to
remove any one of these opening brackets
to balance these opening and the closing
ones out
okay pretty simple and so what I've
decided to do is I've decided to remove
the first opening bracket and keep the
second one you can also do it the other
way both of them are perfectly fine
in the second case we have the input as
1337 wrapped inside of brackets
in this case I have to remove no such
parentheses to convert it to a valid
string because it's already a valid
string all right so let's go ahead and
take a look at some observations the
logic to build up to the solution
now we already talked about this test
case where we removed the first bracket
but I want you to notice one more thing
the question clearly mentioned that we
can only remove brackets that is we have
to remove the minimum number of brackets
to make it a valid shrink in other words
we're only going to remove brackets and
never the lowercase English letters
now this is important because what we
can do is simplify our life a bit what
we can do is look at these characters
instead as indices and we can filter out
all of those characters which are
lowercase English letters
in this way we have simplified the
problem quite a lot and now we only have
to worry about the brackets opening and
closing
all right so let's go ahead and talk
about uh a couple of rules that we
discussed previously first was the thing
where uh why do we use a stack and when
do we use a stack as soon as we see a
leaf quadrant being followed we are
going to use a stack and in this
question is a parenthesis question so we
will use the stack the second thing was
how do we use it well we're going to go
from the left to the right and parse the
input that is for every opening bracket
we see we'll go ahead and add it to the
stack and for regularly every Closing
one we are going to remove an opening
from the stack
so both of them are going to resolve
each other this will make sense in a
second don't worry about it and the
third one is how do we implement this
in this case it is better to use indices
instead of elements okay because we did
a filtering out operation which means
that indices are going to be the way to
go
all right so let's go ahead and get that
input set up and now we have an empty
stack with this so what we'll do is
we'll go ahead and start to iterate from
the left to the right so first we'll go
ahead and look at the element 0. all
right so element at the index 0 is an
opening bracket so we're going to add it
directly onto the stack no questions
asked
then we move on and we iterate further
and we find another opening bracket at
the index four so we'll again add the
index 4 to the stack
oh by the way I am adding these indices
and you have to focus on getting these
indices into the stack the brackets are
there just for the sake of demonstration
and understanding we're actually going
to only have indices in the stack not
the brackets
anyways then we go ahead and reiterate
further and we find that we get a
closing round bracket
now what does this mean
we have found a closing round bracket
which means that it is going to satisfy
the opening round bracket so this 9 is
going to get satisfied with the 4.
both of them mix and match together and
we'll pop the element 4 out of the stack
this is the reason why you see 4 and 9
in the answer
make sense
now we reached the end of the iteration
but 0 Still Remains on the top of the
stack
in other words it never gets satisfied
it never finds any closing bracket to
resolve it
so we'll leave 0 out
so the minimum remove to make valid
parentheses is going to remove the
element 0 from the input
okay let's go ahead and take a look at
another example and this one will really
bring forward the core of the problem
so let's go ahead and start iterating
from the first element we see 0 which is
a closing bracket now this closing
bracket is going to close an opening
bracket
but do we have an opening bracket on top
of the stack
well no we don't even have any brackets
on top of the stack we don't have any
brackets at all
which means that this closing bracket
will never get satisfied it will be
alone always and forever so we are going
to leave it and we're going to iterate
further
all right so now we get an opening
bracket let's go ahead and add it to the
stack pretty simple
next iteration we see that we get a 4.
now this four did what as soon as this 4
got an opening bracket
popped it out and satisfied both of them
so now both the opening and the closing
brackets have satisfied each other which
means both of them are essential to be a
part of the solution
right so let's go ahead and continue
iterating now we get 6 and this is an
opening bracket so let's just go ahead
and add it to the stack
then we get a 7 also added to the stack
and then we get a 9. what do we do when
we get a 9
that's right we'll pop out the 7 and now
both 7 and 9 will satisfy each other
at this point we have 1 4 7 and 9 which
are the
parentheses which satisfy each other in
other words they form an essential part
of the answer however 0 and 6 have to be
removed right we have to remove a
minimum number of brackets and this way
we have found two brackets to remove
from the answer
okay pretty simple uh but what would
happen say if I get a 10
which is a closing bracket just for uh
thought process sake
as soon as I get this 10 what would
happen this 10 is going to satisfy the
element on the top of the stack which is
the element six so 10 and 6 are going to
satisfy each other and so
there is where we end the iteration all
right let's go ahead and take a look at
the optimize solution and uh okay cool
let's go ahead and get started now if
you notice what we have done up till now
is uh have a differentiation between
these blue and the green ones right the
blue ones were ones that never got
satisfied and the green ones were the
ones which got satisfied
so the first thing I'm going to do is
create an array called is okay which is
going to be initialized with 0 for all
the values of the string in other words
I'm going to say none of the elements in
the original shrink ever get satisfied
that is my initial assumption and I'm
going to build upon that later on now
I'll also have an initial stack and
we'll go ahead and start iterating over
all the elements inside of the string so
we'll first get its index another
character for every single element of
the string
now if the characters in opening bracket
what do we do
if the character is an opening bracket
we add it to the stack without asking
any questions now what happens when we
have a closing bracket
when we have a closing bracket we'll
first ask the question here does the
stack exist is there any opening bracket
on the top of the stack because if there
is what do we do if there is we will pop
that element from the top of the stack
and assign its index the value 1. saying
that this opening bracket which we just
popped out is actually a one it is okay
it is a green value as we saw in the
case for one and seven both of them were
opening brackets and they got Satisfied
by four and nine respectively
so one and seven both get this one
and we also assign is okay if I to one
as well saying that because 4 was the
one that popped out one from the top of
the stack one gets satisfied but also
four gets satisfied
so we're going to satisfy both of them
and what is the else condition what if
the stack is non-existent what if we get
a closing bracket and then we realize
that hey wait a second the stack is
empty so we can't really close any
opening bracket
in other words we'll just have to
continue unfortunately skipping over
this current I
alright so was the final lens condition
if you get a opening bracket we append
it to the stack if you get a closing one
we check the stack for emptiness or not
and figure out what to resolve but
there's a final condition which says if
you have English letters well go ahead
and also continue because we don't want
to mess with any lowercase English
letters what we are only going to
message
we are only going to mess with the
indices of the parentheses
all right so at the end of this
iteration is okay is the array which
contains all the information it is the
one which contains the information of
which all are blue which already do and
which one or green the green represents
one and blue represents zero right so
let's go ahead and
iterate further now the goal of this
problem is to return the string
we have to return the string by removing
the minimum number of parentheses
Now using this is okay array we have
already found out all the parentheses
which are essential and which are
non-essential
so what we are going to do is we are
going to go ahead and build the answer
character by character once again
remember all of this what this tag did
was to store the indices of the elements
and this is why the is okay thing worked
out now we are going to iterate over the
string once again and we are going to
ask the question hey is the character a
bracket or not because if it is a
bracket and only if it is okay
only if it has been satisfied then we
added to the answer
because if it's a bracket and it has not
been satisfied we'll have to continue
we'll have to pass over this test case
now was the else condition over here if
the character is a bracket then you will
have to check if it's okay or not but if
a character is not a bracket that is
it's a lowercase English letter then by
default you have to add it to the answer
all right anyways at the final point of
time you go ahead and just return the
answer so let's go ahead and run the
code for sample test cases
and some of this
all right cool so this is it for the
solution to the problem minimum remove
to make valid parentheses hello everyone
and welcome back let's talk about the
problem longest valid parentheses now if
you haven't seen the video on minimum
remove to make valid parentheses this
question will seem out of the blue
however if you have seen that this
question is just a breeze question
because we're going to use the exact
same logic as we saw in the previous one
all right let's go ahead and talk about
the problem statement of formally and
we're given a string of just opening and
the closing brackets that is we only
have opening and the closing around
brackets
the goal of this problem is to find the
longest substring of valid parentheses
in other words let's take an example in
the first test case we have the opening
and the closing brackets which form a
length of two but then we have three
opening brackets which never get closed
in other words the longest substring of
valid parentheses is just 2.
now the second test case is one where we
have opening and closing bracket and
then we have a bunch of opening brackets
the bin one opening bracket at the end
gets closed now what is the longest
substring of valid parentheses we have
in this case two sets of the length two
substring of valid parentheses since
both of them are of land 2 will just
return to as the answer
now what can we say right away about
this kind of question
this kind of question is actually
twofold we have to find two things first
first we have to figure out what all
parentheses are valid or not
because once we have the valid
parentheses in hand once we know which
of them are valid which of them are
invalid we simply have to find the
longest substring of them
right so this is going to be uh broken
down into two parts and if you realize
the answer to the first one is something
we've already seen
all right since there is not a lot to go
on let's go ahead and just build up our
logic from the previous question
as with the previous one we'll set up an
is okay variable that is going to be all
zeros of the length n in other words
it's going to say that you know what
I'll assume none of the brackets opening
or closing ever get satisfied all of
them are zeros
we'll also have an initial
initialization of this track and then
we'll start to iterate our all the
characters in the string
as before we'll check if the character
is a opening bracket or not because if
it is an opening bracket will just
directly add it to the stack
what if it's a closing bracket though
in the else Condition it's a closing
bracket we'll have to check if the stack
exists or not
that is for this current closing bracket
because I've gone in dl's case for this
closing bracket does the stack exist
in other words is there a opening
bracket is there any opening bracket
that you can find which had been put on
the stack
now if you can find that is the case
well then go ahead and make both of them
satisfied that is go ahead and pop the
element from the top of the stack which
is going to be an opening bracket and
set its value to 1 that is that opening
bracket has been satisfied by this
current closing bracket and obviously
that also means this current losing
bracket has been satisfied so we'll set
is okay file to B1
and the off chance that the stack is
empty and you get a closing bracket well
that's just sad we can't really do
anything about that I'm sorry
anyways once we're done figuring out
which of them which of the brackets
opening or closing are valid or not we
simply have to figure out the longest
substring of these valid cases so what
we'll do is we'll set up a count which
is going to be a running count of all
the values and we have a answer which is
going to store the maximum of all of
these counts so what we're going to do
is we're going to iterate in the range
of n that is we'll iterate over every
single index and we'll ask the question
hey is the bracket I'm looking at is the
current bracket okay or not because if
it is okay well that's great news
whatever the count was increase its
value by one why because I found the
case of a valid parenthesis
right so as soon as I know this current
bracket is a part of a valid substring
go ahead and add one to the count else
else what do we do
if at this point of time there is a
bracket which is a stray bracket which
never gets opened or never gets closed
well then we unfortunately have to reset
the counter from zero
okay so the next step is then going to
be simply taking a Max of the answer in
the count because answer wants to store
the maximum possible value of all the
counts ever
all right so this is it for the code
let's go ahead and run it and we'll go
ahead and submit this as well
and cool this gets accepted
so yeah this is it for the solution to
the problem long history valid
parentheses
hello everyone and welcome back this is
the start of a new section on calculator
related questions it builds on top of
our previous work on parentheses related
questions we'll be discussed the exact
reasons why we use a stack how we use it
especially the left to right parsing
method and the implementation level
details that we need to take care of
now what I'm going to do in this video
is establish the we just need two steps
that's right just two steps we need to
know to solve any calculator related
question
in fact both of these steps individually
are interview problems on their own
which means that once we solve both of
them both of these questions we'll be
able to solve any calculator related
question that is like killing three
birds with two stones
all right so the first step is to parse
the input from the infix to the postfix
notation and the second one is to
evaluate the post fix notation
now the first question that you should
ask is wait what is the post fix
notation
so let's go ahead and talk about the
introduction to the postfix notation
first
all right let's go ahead and take a
simple example and let's see that we
have this kind of string that we need to
evaluate
now the infix notation is formally
defined as such
in the infix notation the operator is
fixed in between the operands
again the operator is the focus over
here and the operator is going to be
fixed in between in the operands now
what is the post fixed notation
formally speaking postfix notation is
where the operator is present after the
operands now that might sound a bit
unnatural given that what we have been
looking at all throughout our life is
the infix notation this is the simple in
fixed notation over here and if I ask
you the question hey how would you go
about evaluating this kind of thing what
would you do
the first thing we'll look at is
brackets so we'll evaluate everything
inside of the brackets so 3 times 3
becomes 9. and so this is the expression
that we have now
what do we do next we realize that we
have to do a division operation first
which means that we'll do 9x7 C style
division
so 9x7 will get rounded off to 1. and
now we have 0 minus 1 plus 1. and since
plus and minus are of the same priority
we'll simply cancel both of them out and
say the final answer is nothing but zero
now what have we done over here what we
have done is simply apply a rule called
bod Mass which stands for bracket order
division multiplication addition and
subtraction
this is a rule that is commonly taught
in high school math and is the way we
evaluate any sort of input given to us
however there is a small catch
see if you have brackets inside of
brackets those brackets inside of
brackets need to be resolved first
before you evaluate the brackets
and if you have brackets inside of
brackets inside of brackets then you
resolve then you need to resolve the
innermost bracket first then zoom out
and then zoom out once again
you can see that this sort of nesting is
what can give rise to such complicated
expressions and while the first one on
the top is pretty easy to solve using
the same in fixed notation the second
one becomes much more harder
and so the question arose
whether we can write the expression
unambiguously and we can solve it
efficiently
that is without having to worry about
this Bond Mass rule is there a way we
can write this expression and secondly
is there an efficient way to solve that
expression once you have written it that
way
this is the idea behind post fixed
notation
the both fixed notation simply says that
the operator is present after the
operands in other words if we take an
example like this we have 1 2 plus it is
equivalent to saying 1 plus 2.
again I know this sounds unnatural but
bear with me for a second because
something interesting is going to happen
let's see if we have 1 2 plus 3 star
what will that evaluate to
1 2 plus will become 3 and then we have
3 3 star
in other words we'll have 3 times 3.
what we have done is one plus two inside
of brackets that needs to be resolved
first and then we'll do times three
do you notice something
if we go back the other way around we
have figured out a way to write these
bracketed Expressions into non-bracketed
ones that is one plus two which had to
be resolved first which were present
inside of the brackets we found a way to
write that without using the brackets
how nice is that we were able to figure
out a way to unambiguously write this
expression
all right so this is the general idea
behind using a post-fixed notation and
so we can finally formally talk about
these two steps again the first step was
to convert and parse the input from the
infects to the postfix notation and that
is something we're going to look at in
the next video and then in the next to
next one we'll look at how do you
evaluate the postrix notation all right
so let's get started hello everyone and
welcome back let's talk about how do we
convert the infects to the post fix
notation
as we discussed the infix notation is
one in where we put the operator in
between the operands that is we fix the
operator such as a minus between the
operands such as 0 and 1. so we have
something like 0 minus 1. in the post
fixed notation we have the operator
after the operands where we have
something like 0 1 minus
let's go ahead and take a look at some
examples to understand this vector in
the case we have 1 plus 2 in the infix
notation it gets converted to 1 2 plus
if we have say 5 minus 6 it gets
converted to 5 6 minus
and then if we have something like 1
plus 2 times 3 we have 1 2 plus 3 times
wait a second uh one two sorry one plus
two times three will evaluate to 1 plus
6 which is nothing but 7. but if we
actually evaluate this
will come out to be wrong
that's because 1 2 plus will get
evaluated to 3 first
and then we'll have to do three times
three
giving us the answer nine
this is in fact wrong we are doing one
two plus three times which is wrong
so what do we have to do instead
we have to switch out the ordering of
this Plus
because now what we have done is we have
done one two three Star Plus basically
saying go ahead and multiply 2 and 3
first so 2 times 3 becomes 6 and so
we'll write 1 6 Plus Now 1 6 Plus is
what it's nothing but 1 plus 6 which is
seven and so now we have the correct
answer
but if you notice what happened over
here we realized something The Ordering
of these plus and the star operators
changed
right we had one plus two times three
and it becomes 1 2 sorry it became one
two three Star Plus
so the ordering of the plus and the star
operators change although the ordering
of the operands like one two three did
not change
there's something interesting which
we'll come to very soon again
all right so now we want to formally
talk about how do we convert the infix
notation to the postfix notation right
so let's go ahead and try to work out
the answer one by one
so using the board Master will let me
know we can say that you know what let's
go ahead and do the division operation
first all right so we have to do B by C
first and how are we going to write d by
C
we're going to write it as B C slash all
right pretty simple up till now then
what do we do next
we also realize that there's a b by c
times D we have to do times D in The
Next Step because that is the second
operation we have to follow using the
board Mass rule so what will how do we
write times d
well BC by forms one single operand now
and so we have to multiply BC by with d
BC by is one operating and D is another
and so we can write BC by D star
all right how do we handle the plus case
and the minus case then well it's going
to handle the plus one first so we have
a plus this entire expression now can we
handle that
we can write a in the front and plus the
end and then we have minus E towards the
end so we can write it as e minus
right so we followed the bod Mass
property and we have written down the
infix to the postfix notation
in fact if you break it down we have
something of this sort first we looked
at BC slash then D star then a plus and
then e minus
following the board Mass rule exactly
in fact what we have done here in other
words is that we have somehow implicitly
encoded the information of the bond Mass
rule into the post fixed notation
now to evaluate the post fixed notation
we won't need this bodmas rule at all
because we have already encoded that
information in the structuring of the
post fixed notation
right let me go ahead and explain that
further
what we have done is that we looked at
the bod muscle and we figured out that
we have to First Look at brackets then
order then Division and multiplication
are the same level then addition and
subtraction are the next lower level
right so this is something we've
implicitly encoded into the answer look
at the ordering of The Operators we have
slash first then star then plus and then
minus
I also want you to notice another thing
which I brought up earlier as well
The Ordering of the operands which are a
b c d and e remain the same from the
infix to the post fixed notation
only and Only The Ordering of The
Operators change it went from plus slash
star minus that is it went from a
completely random ordering to a
well-defined ordering where we had
division multiplication addition and
subtraction
so now the question is how do we
implement this how do we make this
happen using formal logic
what we're going to do is we're going to
go ahead and use a stack to do this let
me actually run a simulation and show
you how this works
the first thing we'll do is we'll start
to iterate from the left to the right
and so let's say that we get the first
element as a since this is the operand
and we don't mess with the order of the
operands we are just going to write it
as a part of the answer directly no
thinking twice you see an operand you
write it in the answer that's it as
simple as that
what's the next step
the next step is to iterate further and
we see that we get a plus sign
since the ordering of these operators do
change later on we'll keep them in a
stack for now and we'll see what to do
later on right so now we add this plus
to the stack
then we get the element B and what do we
do since b as an operand We'll add it
and obtain it at the end of the post
fixed answer
all right cool so now we get a slash
now I'm going to ask you a very
important question is it okay to put
this slash after this Plus
or should we instead remove this plus
first and add the slash later on
what should we do
let's think about something that is
going to happen
if you remember stack follows something
called the default ring the last one to
come in is the first one to get out
and notice how the answer on the top
right hand side says
the answer on the top right hand says
that we have to have division then
multiplication then addition and
subtraction that is we have to follow
this highest to lowest ordering in the
post fixed notation that is something
that we have to encode it by default
now if it means that we have to have the
highest operation highest priority
operators first and the lowest ones
later on using this lifo notation what
should be the ordering we follow in the
stack
again the last ones to get in will be
the first ones to get out so if you want
the highest ones to come first in the
answer we'll have to ensure that the
highest ones are the first one to leave
out of the stack
in other words we have to say that the
stack follows the lowest to highest
ordering
so in fact what we have right now plus
followed by a slash is okay
because in the edge case because in the
edge case that we ever decide to remove
both of these elements first will pop
out slash and then Plus
which now exactly follows the ordering
we want
right so I think that should make a lot
more sense now so let's go ahead and
continue iterating we get the element C
and since this is an operand We'll add
it directly add it to the stack
now what do we do when we get a slasher
uh sorry when we get a star operation
remember the board Mass rule
it says the first you resolve brackets
then order then Division and
multiplication at the same level
what does it mean for us to get a
division and a multiplication right now
this is nothing but going to hint us at
the fact that this multiplication
operator is actually going to take this
division operator and kick it out
because both of them are of the same
priority and remember what is the
ordering of the stack The Ordering of
the stack goes from the lowest to the
highest
all right we can't allow elements of the
same priority to stick in together so
we'll have to kick out the Slash and
only then we can add in the star again
if you look at it it is still going to
maintain lowest to the highest ordering
now right it only happens after we kick
out the Slash and if you look on the top
side top right hand side we can see that
you know what this is indeed the correct
way to go so we're thinking about this
correctly
anyways let's keep on iterating further
and see what happens we get a d and
since this is a what since this is an
operand we'll add it directly to the
answer
then we get a minus and now what happens
the priority of minus is much lower than
that of multiplication
which means that this minus is going to
kick out the multiplication you can
think about it this way you can think
that an undeserving candidate comes a
lower priority element comes and it
kicks out all the higher priority or the
equal priority elements out of the stack
it says that you know what you guys are
much higher priority than me minus comes
in and says you know what addition and
multiplication are both either higher or
equal to me so I'll kick you both out
let me just go and stay in the stack so
we'll go ahead and first kick out the
multiplication operator and then we'll
again compare it with the addition one
so now we'll say okay you know what
since plus and minus are both of the
same priority let's go ahead and kick
out plus as well then we'll add minus
into the stack
okay so now we can go ahead and continue
iterating and we get the value e we'll
just add it to the answer and then wait
a second we have reached the end of the
iteration right
after e we have reached the end of the
iteration so what do we want to do if we
want to empty out the contents of the
stack and since there is only one single
element let's just go ahead and add this
at the end
so now you can go ahead and compare both
of them and realize that you know what
we were actually a right all of this
logic worked out for us
so now we want to go ahead and formalize
the logic and write it in terms of code
and we're going to follow the exact same
things that I taught you before
first things first let's create a post
fix array which will return at the end
and now we'll also create a stack for
The Operators the stack is only ever
going to store The Operators
and not the operands
now we want to start iterating over
every single element in the infix and
we're going to call this element token
because it can either be operator or an
operand we don't know yet
now we'll ask the question hey if the
token is not an operator that is if it's
a letter or if it's a number or digit
something like that if the token is not
in the operators then what do we do
hit me is that the token is actually an
operand and in that case we realize that
we just have to directly append it to
the postfix notation we don't ask any
more questions and that is it for an
operand
now what happens if we have an operator
though
then obviously we want to append this
item to the stack
we want to push the token onto the stack
remember stack follows the lowest to
highest ordering which means that we
have to write one or two lines of code
more
and this is very important and this is
something we'll come to by the way in
the next section as well
okay so let me explain what's going on
here
I'm going to say while the stack exists
that is while there are elements in the
stack and the priority of the element on
the top of the stack is greater than the
priority of the current token that is
we're looking at something like a minus
as the current token and the top of the
stack is a star
which we had a case like that before if
we have a case like that then this
current token of lower priority is kick
out is going to kick out the element
from the top of the stack
and it's going to kick that element from
the top of the stack we'll do stack.pop
and whatever the element was kicked out
is going to be appended to the post fix
one directly
so we are going to say while that is
true while the current priority of the
token is lesser than equals to the
priority of the element on the top of
the stack then keep on doing this for
prep operation because we are strict we
want to have a lowest to highest
ordering we can't even allow elements of
the same priority to be there because
even if the priority same we're still
going to make a cake operation we're
going to kick that element out from the
top of the stack and append it to the
post fix notation all right
good so this should make sense now
because we have to follow the lowest to
the highest ordering
okay what's the last step then are we
done
if you remember we had the case where
there was one single element minus in
the stack remaining at the end so we'll
actually have to handle cases like that
as well and we have to say you know what
while the stack exists while there are a
bunch of operators in the stack go ahead
and pop that element of the stack and
append it to the post six now obviously
in this kind of case we will only ever
have one single element like that
okay anyways uh all of this was to
convert this kind of input as we saw on
the top from the infix notation to the
postfix notation
but now I ask you the question is it
possible
to somehow include in Brackets as well
because look at the inputs we have never
talked about brackets up till now we've
only talked about operands and operators
what if there are brackets
all right let's go ahead and write some
more code and since brackets are of
higher priority since you know in bodmas
you will be always take care of brackets
first let's go ahead and handle the
cases of brackets in the first two
conditions so the first will first thing
we'll see is that if the token is an
opening bracket what do we do
we will append this token on top of the
stack we'll say you know what this is
going to start of a new expression that
we need to take care of earlier on so
let's go ahead and append this token on
the top of the stack
okay now what
well we want to say you know what if the
token is a closing bracket then we need
to do something more
as soon as we get a closing round
bracket what do we want to do
we want to take care of all the elements
present between this opening round
bracket and the closing round bracket
so what we are going to do is we're
going to say you know what while the
stack of top while the stack top is not
an opening bracket go ahead and kick out
all the elements one by one
so what we are going to say is
everything in between of these two
brackets between this opening round
bracket and the closing round brackets
go ahead and pop those elements from the
top of the stack and keep on appending
them to the post fix notation
one last thing that we have to do what
is the one last thing the stack top is
currently now having the opening round
bracket
as the Stacked out why is that because
that is when the while loop exists
because the stack top is going to have
the opening round bracket which means
that we have to take care of that once
again
we have to do a stack.pop operation
saying that you know what we don't
really care about brackets in the post
fix notation
because that was the whole point of post
fixed notation to get rid of the
brackets in the weird board Mass
ordering
now let me ask you this one question and
this is a kind of a special trick case
that we need to take care of remember
the board Mass rule right and what I
promised at the start was that we will
be able to somehow implicitly encode the
information of the infix notation in the
postfix notation right and we were able
to do that by handling the cases of
brackets separately and division
multiplication addition subtraction
all right
but now if I ask you let's go ahead and
also formally Define the priority what
is that going to look like
because we use this priority over here
in the while loop right
now how do we Define the priority well
the priority will be a little bit
different
so obviously the order has the highest
priority then division multiplication
and then addition subtraction but the
bracket the opening bracket will have
the lowest priority
why is that you ask
it has a very interesting reason behind
it all right let's say that we have a
bunch of elements in the stack let's say
there's a opening bracket and now let's
say that the operator is simply a star
so we have an opening bracket and a star
after it
now let's say that the minus comes right
so what is minus going to do minus is a
lower priority element so it is going to
kick out the star out of the stack
but at the same time we want to ensure
that this minus does not kick out the
opening round bracket
because it's not minus his job to handle
that it's the job of the closing bracket
to handle that in its own while
condition
so we are going to have opening bracket
having the lowest priority so that the
minus or any other sign in fact is never
able to kick it out of the stack all
right so in this video we learned how to
convert the infix notation to the
postfix notation now I promise you in
the next one we're going to look at how
do we evaluate the post fix notation and
that is going to be a so so much simpler
than this code hello everyone and
welcome back let's talk about how to
evaluate the post fix notation in the
previous video we looked at how do we
convert the infix notation to the post
fixed notation and I promised early on
that the post switch notation is going
to be a very easily computable way to
get the answer for any calculator
related question
what we're going to do is very simple
I'm going to create a stack and now
we'll see that we're going to start
iterating from the left to the right
now for elements like 0 which we'll get
as operands we are going to push them
onto the stack without asking any
questions as soon as we get another
operand let's say in the case of one we
are also going to the push it to the top
of the stack
but things get a bit more interesting
when we get an operator because now what
does this operator mean what is this
entire 0 1 minus thing mean
this means that we have to do 0 minus 1.
in other words we have to pop one out of
the stack we have to also pop out Zero
from the stack take their negation that
is do 0 minus 1 because we have gotten a
current value as the negative minus sign
so we have to do 0 minus 1 and then put
it back into the stack
right so what did we do you get an
operand you add it to the stack no
asking questions Twice But as soon as
you get an operator go ahead and remove
two values from the top of the stack do
the evaluation and then add them back in
okay let me continue and show you what
this means
so we get three this is an operand we'll
add it to the stack we get another three
operand add to the stack
what do we do when we get a star as soon
as we get a star we'll pop one value out
we'll pop another value out multiply
both of them since this is a star
operation find the value and push this
answer back onto the stack
okay again what do we do when we get a 7
add this one to the stack now what do we
do when we get a slash
what will the be the next step
since we have a slash we're going to pop
out the last two elements seven and nine
we're going to take the division nine by
seven and this is the C style division
so we'll get the answer as one
so we'll get the answer as 1 and we'll
push this back onto the stack
and then finally we have the plus
operation where we'll pull out one we're
also pop out minus one add them together
get the answer 0 and then push it back
onto the stack
at the end of this iteration one thing
is guaranteed there will be only one
single element inside of the stack and
that will be the answer
okay so what are the rules formally
speaking we do two things first if you
have an operand you add it to the stack
else you pop the last two elements
evaluate them and then add them add
their result onto the stack again all
right so let's go ahead and look at the
code implementation of the same problem
this is the problem evaluate reverse
polish notation which is the same as the
post fix notation on lead code all right
what are we going to do first things
first initialize a stack right the stack
is going to be an empty list
I'm also going to Define these Ops which
is basically going to Define for this
character for this current operator
represented as a string as a character I
want to do this operation I'm going to
do operator dot add for minus I'm going
to do the subtraction for the
multiplication I'm going to do 1 and
then for the division I am not
going to do floor Dem
right these are the two options because
we have one as true div which is just a
slash and the floative which is actually
double slash so it might look tempting
for you to do double slash in when it
comes to python code although in other
languages you can just do slash and get
away with it in Python do not do double
slash because that is floor div that
does not work as intended as you want
and it's going to give you issues when
it comes to negative values uh I won't
go into much more detail in that you can
go check out some of the links down
below anyways what we're going to do
next is we're going to iterate over
these token given in the input tokens
so what was the goal we have to first
figure out if it's operand or not
now we'll say if the token is not in the
operators that is if the token is not of
plus minus multiplication or division
symbols that means it's a integer value
given to us so what we're going to do is
we're going to convert that token to an
end value and append it to the stack all
right
cool so now what we're going to do in
the else condition the else conditions
when we have these kind of operators
with us
so what we want to do is pop out two
elements from the top of the stack do
the computation and then append the
result back into the stack
now just a quick run through of what's
Happening note that the ordering of
these matters a lot we are first going
to pop out N2 and then N1
again uh look at all of the simulation
actually Vijaya I didn't explain it back
them but is something very important
look at what we have done
right so as soon as we get the plus
operation what do we do we first pop out
this element from the top of the stack
which is going to take the second place
and then we're going to pop out this
element which is going to take the first
place so this one we currently popped
out this guy is the N1 and the element
on the right hand side is the N2 right
this makes more sense for division as
well as subtraction because they are not
exactly commutative all right anyways
first will pop out N2 and then will pop
out N1 whatever the result is we are
going to get it by using this Ops of
token that is whatever this token is say
it's a plus sign so we'll go ahead into
this dictionary and access this operator
dot add function and this is going to
take into values again N1 and N2
whatever the result is we're going to
append it to the stack
now one last thing that we realized one
last thing that we realized was that the
stack is going to have only one single
element at the end of this iteration
which is going to be the answer so we
return it at the end and uh now let's go
ahead and test the code out
so we'll run the code once okay looks
good and we'll go ahead and submit this
all right cool so this works out and uh
yeah this is sort of a formal
implementation of evaluating reverse
polish notation by the way if this seems
too fancy you can write some manual code
here as well you can just say LF token
is a plus sign just go ahead and do this
this this
and result will be nothing but
N1 plus into and something like this and
so you can do LF for all of these sort
of cases right if that seems too fancy
you can do it this way as well
all right cool so this is it and I'll
see you in the next one hello everyone
and welcome in this video we're going to
implement basic calculator one two and
three all using the same exact code
believe me I'm going to do a copy paste
like nothing you've seen before all
right so the first thing we want to do
with basic calculator is realize that we
have already written most of the code in
these two functions post function is
going to convert the infix notation to
the post fixed notation and the second
one is going to evaluate the post fix
notation again both of these functions
have been covered in separate videos of
their own which each of their own
intuitions observations and formal code
that we wrote down
in this question however we have to
write one more function which is going
to do the parsing or the cleaning up
thing so we're going to do and create a
read function which is going to take in
the string and return us the infix
notation all right that is the goal of
this problem
okay why do we do this by the way
look at this the input we are given is a
string and so we can have a case like 3
plus a bunch of spaces one space times
337
okay so nothing too special but you can
see that this is a hard string to work
with mostly because won't it be so nice
if you can actually have a list of
tokens that we need to focus on that is
if you have something like say uh
something that gave us three then
something that gave us Plus
then punch Then star then 337. won't it
be nice if we have a infix notation laid
out like this right this will make
things a lot simpler because we don't
have nasty spaces to deal with and all
of the numbers have been dealt with that
is 337 actually is considered as 337 and
not three three and seven right these
are some of the cases that we have to
handle and so what we are going to do is
convert and read the string into the
infix notation so the infix notation is
going to be a list which will return at
the end
how do we go about making this happen
well we'll go ahead and write a by Loop
so we'll say I equals to 0 and while
I is lesser than the length of s go
ahead and keep on doing some computation
the first thing we'll do is clear out
all the spaces so if the SFI the current
character I'm looking at if it's a space
well just go ahead and ignore this I
don't really want to mess with this
what do we do
well in the case of space we simply
ignore but in the case of operators we
can't really do that because we have to
add these individual operators to the
infix notation list
so what I'm going to say is if if s of I
is present inside of the operators by
the way these operators is the variable
over here which is simply just the
brackets and the multiplication division
signs blah blah if the current character
I'm looking at is an operator well then
go ahead and add this to the infix list
so I'll do infix dot append the current
s of I I'll also do I plus equals to 1.
all right what's the else condition vl's
condition is some case where we have a
digit like 2 or 234 or 345 things like
that so we have to handle cases like
these separately right what I'm going to
do is I'm going to create a number
variable which is going to be an empty
string and I'm going to say you know
what while
the SFI dot digit is digit actually so
while the SFI I'm looking at is a digit
well then go ahead and append this to
the number so I'll do number plus equals
to the S of I
and once I'm done with this oh by the
way I'll also do I plus equals to 1
always and once I'm done with this
iteration when the saturation stops when
I get either a space or an operator I'm
going to say you know what go ahead and
stop at this point of time and please go
ahead and do infix dot document p number
one thing that we always check whenever
we write these by Loops is whether s of
I will actually exist or not there might
be a case where this I plus 1 might take
it out of the length of the string so
we'll also have to say
keep it limited to that while I is less
than length of s and this happens then
do these computations
okay so we are almost done but there's
one more thing that we have to keep in
mind and this is sort of a well kind of
a pain implementation that we have to
take care of
because here's the thing the minus could
be used as an unary operation that is in
the case of -1 and sort of minus of 2
plus 3 all of these cases like all of
these cases are valid
but in one of the codes we have seen
previously we did not handle these unre
operations so what is a hacky way around
this okay this is going to be a very
happy way but what we can do is we can
add a 0 in front of it so as soon as we
get an honorary minus we're going to do
0 minus that thing so in the case of
minus 1 we'll instead write it as 0
minus 1 and instead of minus of 2 plus 3
we are going to write it as 0 minus 2
plus 3. this is going to make the rest
of the implementation consistent with
the logic
so we'll have to say you know what uh
before you do this please go ahead and
check if the SFI is actually a
minus sign or not because if it's a
minus sign then we need to do some extra
steps before we can jump into solution
all right when is a character when is
this minus sign and unre operated
this is a ninery operator in a bunch of
cases we have to say first of all if
I equals 2 equals to 0 then go ahead and
do infix dot append 0.
that is if this minus sign is the first
thing you ever get in the entire string
if it is the first position in the
string then you have to append a 0
before you append this current operator
all right but this is not the only case
all right so we can have another case
where we say uh say 5 minus of minus 2.
all right so this is a case where the
preceding element with the element to
the previous of this minus is actually
an opening bracket so we'll also have to
take care of this condition and say that
you know what if the current minus the
zerothal element is the zeroth place
where an append 0 to the infix before
you append the minus or we have to say
or
if the S of I minus 1 If the previous
element If the previous character
was an opening bracket
then what
then you have to take care
to also append the zero by the way just
to make sure that this I minus 1
actually exists we have to write one
more condition and say that this I minus
1
this I minus 1 should be greater than
equals to 0. right so pretty simple
and uh yeah I think we're done now let's
go ahead and run the code once oh by the
way we still have to write all these
functions now so the first thing we'll
do is go ahead and read
the S string given as the input and this
will get me the infinix notation
for the infix notation I'm going to
convert it to the post fix notation so
post fix
equals to in fixed to postfix
of impacts
and finally I'm going to return
evaluate postwix
all right cool let's go ahead and test
this out hopefully it works
ah God damn it okay it's a typo line 20.
is digit
okay cool fixed again hoping that we
don't have any issues
let's just hope that we don't have any
more issues it's going to be a pain
otherwise all right I'm gonna go ahead
and submit this let's hope and great we
got it accepted cool so now as I
promised before we're going to do a
massive copy pasting thing I'm gonna
control C go here and uh
paste this baby over here let's go run
the code once again get it accepted here
all right cool looks good and once
finally in the basic calculator 3 is
going to do the submit directly YOLO all
right cool so we get this code accepted
in all the three questions just by using
these simple Logics what did we do we
first read the input string and we sort
of cleaned it up and converted the
string to a list of tokens then we went
ahead and evaluated and converted the
infix to the post fix notation and
finally we evaluated the postrix
notation
all right cool uh this is it for this
video and this ends the string related
section of Stack questions next up we're
going to look at monotonic Stacks which
is more of a mathematical side of stacks
all right